he brings his bishop out to the side of
the board before it's too late notice
how it's really blocked the pawn
structure and in block positions knights
are better than bishops so here he wants
to remove white knight at the cost of
his own i can see ivanka's hand is is up
in the air and it does look like there's
a one i don't know if that's there hello
hello that's like you know it does look
like there's a tactic here right
definitely i mean
there might well be but it's trade of
queens right yeah i mean well
i've always found that that favors the
side with the clamping pawns but he's
gone through it gone for it you know
what i think it might be a very clever
decision because i actually think
black's position was so bad after that
big clamp that he had to do something
magnus's face it was frozen on that face
i don't know if we can go back to her
but it was frozen on the most surprised
grumpy face i've seen in ages
and uh he's surprised because yes white
has won a pawn with a tactic there
white's knight jumping out the way
gaining a pawn in the process and
white's bishop snacking on the black
bishop but if you look at the quality
now black's knights are fantastic
and